[Musique]
promotion destin Jerry monstrueuse
fête de profileur de cannabis féminin s'il vous plaît
couvrir de sangre de nevada stressant
Kanata bon pour les paladins au début de ma
famille à partir de ce que c'est un récipient en métal
où dois-je attendre les conseils sur
ce que constamment bien aucun respect laissez
nous allons au-delà de la connaissance Je le crois
ou non Je ne devrais pas être dehors J'ai un cancer
mais j'aimerais que
ça m'aide la marijuana alors je suis ici pour
obtenir quelque chose pour m'aider avec mon cancer
[Musique]
Je suis  pas vraiment inquiet à ce sujet en ce
moment
car vous pouvez voir la distanciation sociale de tout le monde
les magasins prenant des précautions
ou ne manipulant pas d'argent liquide les autres caissiers
portent des gants et se désinfectent les mains donc j'ai
l'impression qu'ils prennent autant de
précautions que n'importe qui pourrait
[Musique]
[  Musique]